foreign
hi Dr John
um right off the bat please know I'm a
super nerd and I've condensed this
complicated issue into several grouped
bullet points that I'm going to try to
get through as quickly as possible
because I'd really rather hear your
voice well thank you for thank you for
being a super nerd in our super nerd
gang that's super good
your latest book is life-changing and
every night I ask one question to my
daughter from your human teen cards and
have some amazing conversations I'm
going to jump into my question right now
compliments make you awkward so how can
everything makes me awkward Shay
everything
how could how can my husband and I
didn't ask and currently only engage in
obligatory sex once every few months
and okay so here come my detail bullets
all right let's do it my my husband and
his siblings
were horrifically physically and
sexually abused by a monster who was
also his biological father
my my husband says he has no sexual
desire however as time goes on I think
he really does it's just he's never been
in love before he's never had a loving
relationship and he's sex is always just
meant abuse and hate
um oddly enough the more we talk about
this the more uncomfortable I feel
initiating because I'm learning more and
more how uncomfortable he is with sex
and selfishly I hate to initiate because
it makes me feel ugly and like a big old
man and no matter how many times my
husband reassures me he loves me and
finds me attractive it's just his
actions are speaking louder than his
words now Genesis I have to include
these historical bullets I'm sorry I'm
going as fast as no you hey hold on one
second take a big deep breath okay I'm
trying to read these like a secretary
like it's not my own issue so I don't
forget no I know I know you are you are
doing you're you're very courageous and
I could hear you hanging in there and so
thank you thank you take your time take
your time I'm in no rush I don't have
anything else going on today I'm just a
double YouTuber so I'm good well we my
husband and I we we met in kindergarten
we're friends forever lost touch we
reconnected uh 30 years later we married
and moved in together six years ago uh
after we had both gone through a divorce
we both had three children and we each
had one minor child still left at home
we we each had one daughter both the
same age
for four years for the first four years
of our marriage he would live with us
for 10 days and then travel five hours
up north to stay four days with his
minor daughter
for his visitation two years ago his
teenage daughter started going off the
rails and we had to have a come to Jesus
moment I don't know if I can say that
but we had to have a very difficult talk
and we made the decision that he needed
to move back up north until both of our
girls graduate which is thank God only
279 days from today
no not that you're counting right
right the past two years we only see
each other two uh sometimes four to five
days every month you had a very similar
call a while ago with a man the roles
were reversed and you recommended him
read the book Come As You Are by the way
can't ever get that book cover image out
of my head thanks for that
I started started reading it
Dr John I had to stop because it just
seemed so focused on the female who was
having trouble with sex and I just found
it very hard to translate because there
just seems to be something uniquely cool
about the female in the relationship not
getting any I could talk it forever
about that yeah okay so let me get you
there that book is written for two women
about women and so I actually take that
book out of context and I recommend Men
read it
um and so yes you're like it's it's
overwhelmingly female because it's Dr
nagoski wrote it to women right it's a
it's a letter to women I've just found
it super helpful for entertaining the
conversation like it
yeah anyway it's it's mind-blinding for
men and women
um but I can't I do get your point
um but that's that was actually the
point of it but okay go ahead yeah and
so as that said I I I've never talked
this is the first time I'm telling
anybody this other than my husband and
and so I figured I'd start by telling Dr
John Jenna Kelly and your mom and um so
how do we start having a crazy awesome
sex life and and of course I mean my
husband and me of course and yes please
be as direct and honest with me as you
can hit me where it hurts no I don't
know there's nothing to hurt here
um I'm heartbroken here with you
um
you told me a lot about your husband you
told me a lot about his past you told me
a lot about his daughter he told me a
lot about some hard decisions y'all had
to make in your marriage which is going
to be better generationally and
long-term and all that
you've never told me what you want
what do you need what do you feel what
what's going on with you
[Music]
and hey you've never said these words
out loud before and you are someone who
loves your husband and probably have
taken on partly a maternal role for him
because you want to protect him from
getting hurt again like his evil father
did
and when you think I really want this or
if y'all are about to have sex and even
if it's just like y'all are about to
have sex and it's just get off sex right
it's just married couple let's just do
this sex and he quit
like you get angry and then you feel
guilty for getting angry or you get
frustrated and you get angry for getting
frustrated right so for the first time
what do you actually need what do you
want
I need that physical connection with him
it's like our marriage just is so
he is the perfect man for me
and I am the perfect woman for him
this is and I'm a bit of a perfectionist
and this is the only piece of our
marriage
that needs help
but it's it's a big piece
it's
awesome and I'm so excited but it's
getting to the point now where
so stressful like okay and am I going
now he when I initiate
he never stops me and you know
things are Mechanicals whatever and I
just
I want him to come on to me
like when I'm I've actually cut myself
off kind of socially for from
two of my girlfriends I have
because who used to be close with me
because we used to talk about
you know we
women say things to each other like oh
your hubby's coming into town I'm so
excited you're gonna get lucky
and uh you know and then they complain
about
their marriages and how annoying it is
that their husbands are constantly
coming on to them and I just want to
punch him in the face and I don't
but okay so let's let me back all the
way out here
um
when y'all first got married
was it hot and heavy or has it always
been stilted and awkward
it seemed to be hot and heavy in the
beginning okay and then as as we started
learning more about each other and he
started opening up more I started
becoming
more worried um there you go because I I
kept learning okay so let me stop you
right there okay you said earlier on
that
he maybe had never been in love before
and he's absolutely been in love before
he's probably had very few moments in
his life when his body felt truly safe
yes and he has a radar system on his
body for a lack of safety or for tension
or for
not with me or for using me
that you and I could never understand
it is a fine-tuned NASA built radar
system
and so he finds you and he's perfect for
you and you're perfect for him and then
he starts opening up and his body says
I'm safe with this one
it's never been safe and it's safe with
this one
and the more you learn the more your
body
starts feeling awkward or a little bit
weird or maybe just absolutely and I
know we're not allowed to say this out
loud
absolutely revolted disgusting
you know what I mean
and it's hard it's and then all of a
sudden like I like my your sexual desire
gets tangled up in his abuse the whole
thing is gets to be a mass and then you
stop talking a little bit or you make
your body gets a little bit tense when
he reaches over right and so it's just
it's it's by degrees
and then we land here what you've done
with your girlfriends I would tell you
is 100 exact opposite you know what both
of you are right now dreadfully lonely
dreadfully lonely
and that isolation begets isolation and
when you get isolated your brain goes
back to the old mechanisms that keep it
safe
and for your husband that is get away
from me
and for you it's whatever it happens to
be
if you if you feel
so unattractive and so sexy coming on to
him
that also has ramifications about how he
makes you feel you see what I'm saying
you just get into this weird dance and
now we're off to the races
and you're both racing on different
tracks you end up way far away okay
when's the last time y'all sat down and
exhaled
and said okay we had a plan we had a
two-year plan
we've done it for a year and a quarter
and I don't know if we're gonna make the
rest of the plan can we alternate can we
change something up can we reconsider
can we fill in the blank when's the last
time y'all sat down and said I miss you
I miss your body on my body I missed
being with you I meant right when's the
last time you've had that conversation
uh within the week I mean we have those
conversations regularly okay and what is
his response
I feel trash it's
what's more important than our
relationship is that both of our
daughters who are both seniors in high
school their lives don't get disrupted
disagree totally disagree you know why
because their lives are completely
disregarded I mean disrupted because
their parents
are an anxious wreck right now
never looked at it that way before they
are absorbing both of y'all's tension
and both of your loneliness which turns
into for many parents turns into
neediness and your kids find themselves
propping you guys up which they can't do
and that turns into them saying stupid
stuff like I hate you or get away from
me I don't want to talk to you which
they really do but they their bodies are
saying I can't carry this it's this
adult
they're disrupted they're disrupted
and so that that ship has left the
harbor the question is what can you
provide then the greatest gift you can
give those two girls is a picture of
what a healthy marriage looks like the
great and I'm not saying you have to
live together you're already in this
thing you're 200 days away right it's
almost to the end here
right
but four or five days out of a month
isn't cutting it
it's just not working
and on top of it
I I'm gonna say something that I'm not
certain of okay but I wonder after a a
marriage three kids a whole I wonder how
much you are struggling with his
childhood sexual abuse
more than him
yeah that's I think this is old news for
him yeah it happened that I have just
started struggling with yes you're
exactly right why are you struggling
with it
okay this is why I just realized it
when we have time together
and he reaches over for me
all that goes through my head is he's
only doing this because he knows I need
it that's bull crap [ __ ] you know it
though because he wants me why do you
tell this this has nothing to do with
his child abuse this has to do with you
where did that story come from that
you're not beautiful that when you come
on to your husband and you just want to
ravage out like that you're a man and
you're gross where does that story come
from
probably you know no no hold on don't
probably you know exactly where it comes
from Shay you know exactly where it
comes okay well I don't know if this is
if this is the right answer but there's
no wrong answer but you know where it
comes from
I had
a great childhood I was an only child
for the majority of my life and um
but looking that after I read your book
looking back on the reality I was one of
these people I had the perfect life I
had the perfect life and looking back I
was like wait a minute I've never had a
mother for the first 13 years of my life
my mom I always had to be the mother to
my mom my mom was very driven by her
appearance and her and her sex drive
everything was about her appearance you
know she got a facelift at the age of
40. she left my father and I when I was
13 to live to to move half to move
across the country with my dad's best
friend
and just abandoned us and you know so
listen do you hear that you hear it
though
for your
how that got turned into at a great
childhood is madness
it's bad it's the stories we tell right
it's how we get through the day it's all
good but here's the deal
you've been carrying other adults your
entire life you've been somebody's Mom
since the day you were born
and when it comes to sex you just want
to be able to let go
and so you can blame him
his father the evils of sexual abuse
which will rear its ugly head throughout
your relationship there's no question
about that
but you have to take ownership of the
story that when he reaches for you it's
not really it's it's it's perfunctory
it's a it's a job it's not because he's
all about you
because you're not all about you
and that's why you can't get through
Emily's book
because that book tells women to
celebrate their bodies
in how their bodies actually work and
what sex in a rambunctious marriage can
actually be like
and you don't believe it am I right
yeah because
you're right because I kind of got mad
at the book yes because that book oh man
it's not just because of the zipper
vagina yeah it's a terrible yeah I would
not have done that card I don't know
Emily I've never met her I've never
talked to her in my life I would be like
I see what you did there right yes but
listen that's why you didn't like the
book because the book called you out
you are lonely as bloody hell sister
and you are craving touch and that is
butting up against a little girl
who has been told since you were zero
that you are not beautiful you are not
enough and God help me if I turn into my
mom
yeah
and you don't deserve that and your
husband doesn't deserve that
and by the way your daughter doesn't
deserve that either
is it possible that in an effort to not
be like your mom you turn the whole
faucet off
and you're dying to thirst
yeah I mean
I mean okay so here I'm going to run
through a couple of things here okay I
um Jenna had let me know just she gave
me a couple of sentences about this call
before so I made a couple of notes here
it's gone a different direction than I
thought it was but here's a couple of
things I'm gonna give you it's just
tactically okay
is that cool
yes please okay
first thing here is
both of you are gonna have to
practice not disconnecting during sex
when I say disconnecting your head
starts going he doesn't even want to be
doing this he doesn't even like this I'm
gross I need to turn this way so he
can't see me in this particular light
you gotta stop that you're gonna have to
quit right
yes okay and he's gonna have to practice
when the shame demons come
and I my I've never been sexually abused
by my father right but those men I've
talked to it sounds like the shame
Shadow is is is concrete it's so heavy
right that blanket of Shame he's gonna
have to practice not disconnecting
which also means both of you are going
to find yourselves in the middle of sex
and one of you is going to tap out and
say I gotta stop
and then you're gonna have to figure out
what to do that extra energy and here's
an idea well I gotta be careful I see
this there's it may be well let's see
here that you come up with alternative
ways to dispel the energy in their
presence is that fair and that gives
somebody an opportunity
to be in the Sexual Energy presence of
their spouse and
not feel like they have to participate
in their bodies taken over for them what
I'm saying is you're going to have to
practice putting yourselves in awkward
situations
and you have to keep going
and when your body starts to feel ugly
you're gonna have to challenge that
story
that's the only way through it you
cannot think your way through this
does that sound scary
foreign
but it brings up this question okay what
is the question I have
I don't know
specific details of his abuse and this
sounds so dumb when it's I'm saying it
out loud but I'm gonna say it anyway I
have this
I feel like I need to know the details
of his abuse so that I can avoid those
things because I feel like different
details don't take that from him
and what does that mean don't take that
like just let him deal with that
is that what you mean like I shouldn't
even be thinking about that he needs to
tell you his needs
do you think about his ex-wife having
when you're having sex with him
no and why would you think about his
childhood
that's your hang up and he doesn't need
you to protect him you're not his mom
you've been your mom's mom you've been
your dad's mom you're not his mom you're
his wife foreign
I realize I have more Hang-Ups than you
and I'm sorry I've made your story my
story and that's not fair
and I need you to tell me
that if you're ever uncomfortable you
will say you're uncomfortable because
you feel it when he's uncomfortable
and or you perceive it that he's
uncomfortable and then that sends you
off spinning and you don't come back for
days and since y'all can't see each
other and you don't bump into each other
and you don't hug each other while
you're and accidentally get junk on each
other when you're brushing teeth or
whatever since you don't have that in
those moments it's just you alone making
up stories
is that fair yes
and so hey you'll let me know if I ever
cross a line then you feel like
your your child self it comes out to
protect you during sex comes back you'll
let me know and he'll probably look at
you and say yes I'll let you know
now take your clothes off that's
probably what I was gonna say right
that is so freeing like you're not as
Mom you can't control it you can't
control it he's got to be a grown-up and
tell you I need to stop and then you
gotta have a plan for okay he told me to
stop it's not because I'm ugly it's not
because I'm a man it's because his
body's getting a little bit overwhelmed
so I'm gonna take care of business right
here and we've already talked about this
is that fair
yeah would it be fair for now I'm a very
structured spreadsheet oriented
dork and I live and die by spreadsheets
and but would it be fair
are ridiculous for us to together
establish rules like absolutely every
time we're together we should there's
there's a that's that's practice right a
good coach has practice outlined
for for before they go to practice you
can't just have a coach being like Oh
Let's do uh shooting drills Let's uh
let's do free throw you can't do that
well the practice is working towards an
end goal right
that's why you have agendas before
meetings I will also tell you you've got
to make space inside you can't have
Reckless and free and wild sex with your
husband if it all comes out of a
spreadsheet
I know right and so but you can you can
have in a spreadsheet we are gonna We
Are Gonna practice intimacy on these
days
and I do have couples push back like man
if I start having to put sex on the
calendar it's not it's not good anymore
that's stupid that's Hollywood bullcrap
it's great
it's just different
you don't schedule it doesn't happen
when we live together we have that we
have that rule like once every week we
each had to initiate once and honestly
that was the best time of our marriage
with that yes okay here I'm going to
give you um you may have heard this on
the show I think or maybe I did it a
live event I was kind of kidding not
really I wasn't I wasn't kidding but
it's not a product that exists okay
here's my here's my recommendation to
you
I'm going to teach you the secrets of
the John Delaney erotic envelope system
it doesn't really exist but that's just
what I call it I want you to go to
Walgreens and get five ten envelopes
it's gonna cost you a grand total of 11
cents or something like that
I want you to give your husband five of
these give your husband ten of these and
you take five and you take ten and
inside of them I want you to take a
scrap of paper and write down whatever
you think
whatever you want
we're gonna do this we're gonna try that
we're gonna try this
and the commitment both of you have is
we're going to randomly draw one we're
going to pull it out of the drawer once
once a week once a month once every
other day I don't care do it as much as
you want and we commit to doing
whatever's on that card
and sometimes it's like french kissing
what in the world that's just that's it
that's what we're doing we're going to
hold hands of French kiss you know we're
gonna do we're gonna sell the front
portions hug
and he can get all bent out of shape
that's what was on the card and then
there may be another card but you're
like I don't know how that's physically
possible but we're willing to either a
go for it or B we're going to talk about
it and I I've heard from couples all
over often the talking about it the
Curiosity
is not the oh gross I'm not doing that
it's
okay
um tell me about this what is it about
this that makes you be like I want to
try that or this sounds like it would be
awesome any number like
and be willing to give that a whirl and
now it's got structure now it's from the
envelope it's not this awkward the
awkwardness gets channeled into this
third neutral object right not us and it
gives us a way to practice gives us
inner ways to enter into this this
uncomfortable space
but back it all the way out okay as we
wrap up this call Shay
number one
this distance is killing you y'all got
to figure something else out whether you
got to just keep driving a crummy car
and fly on a weekend for rendezvous
you're gonna meet halfway I don't care
what it is y'all got to figure out
something with this time second thing is
wrecking your marriage or starving your
marriage is not helping your daughters
it's just not okay it's not it's not
it's not I don't know what it looks like
for y'all individually we'd have to have
a bunch more sessions together to figure
that out but it's not it's not helping
it the third thing is
you may have more hang up with his
sexual past than he does his abuse his
whatever so
you make a commitment I'm not going to
disconnect during sex and ask him make
the commitment to not disconnect and if
you got to we got to talk about it the
fourth thing is practice the
recklessness practice the laughter
practice the all right let's give this a
whirl and there's gonna be disaster when
you practice you miss shots a lot of
them right you throw it past and it goes
out into off the wall or into the stands
that's a cool practice and know that
while we're practicing it's not going to
be because I'm an idiot or I'm
unattractive I'm not beautiful Etc and
my sister Shay I love you and I'm so
proud of you and you're being brave and
courageous thank you for telling your
story
it's time for you to stop being
everybody's mom
and I think you would be well served to
go sit with a counselor and say I need
to learn to love myself because I'm
worth being loved
you're worth being loved okay